jetzt sagst wir vor allem journalisten
soll natürlich nicht rührselig werden
wenn sie jetzt diese ergebnisse hören
das aussehen angesprochen man muss
tatsächlich sagen wenn jones hat als er
dann vor jetzt tatsächlich und stunden
das verkünden konnte er war mehr als
ärgerlich es gab tränen
und tatsächlich der freude darüber dass
donald trump jetzt nicht sein nächster
präsident ist und das wollen uns noch
einmal anschauen
christmas soundtracks
denn es kann spiele hertha bsc herrscht
übereinstimmung rechtfertig auch nicht
von streets die stelle nur ja gänzlich
liefern nur ergänzende fakten ich glaube
was du sagst im moment dass ihr beide
aussage ist interessanter ausdruck eines
gesamt phänomens viele dinge die dort
für die donald form steht und dazu
gehört mit sicherheit
frauenfeindlichkeit sind sichtbar
geworden durch sein wesen so wie viele
seiner erfolge unsichtbar geworden sind
durch sein wesen wenn wir einmal auf
bekannten schauen wollen ja dann hatte
clinton im weißen haus dinge getan die
heute in der heutigen standards als
missbrauch gelten würden bill clinton
hat sich nach seiner präsidentschaft von
bereichen freunden durch die welt jetten
lassen in flugzeugen mit dem spitznamen
r faktoren ja lolita express ist es ist
nicht so dass wir die phänomene die wir
bei donald trump sehen weil beide
klicken oder bei anderen us präsidenten
ein wenn ich dann einmal kurz nicht
gesehen hätten ist er aber aber sie
treten halt besonders zum vorschein es
ist gut und das ist das ist die
verantwortung von donald trump durch das
wesen von donald trump hat alles dafür
getan dass nach außen zu kehren und und
es in gewisser weise ja fast zu einem
kult zu erheben
und deswegen muss er jetzt damit leben
dass dieses unsägliche verhalten
in der stunde der niederlage natürlich
besonders gegen ihn zurück schlag ein
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren